(upbeat music)
- I allow my brain to do the work
to get into my creative zone.
When I have a problem to resolve,
sometimes I just sleep on it
and I let my subconscious mind work
through resolving problems
and solving problems.
Our brains are always at work
like trying to defragment and break apart
the things that we encounter.
So I spend a little time thinking about
how I can approach things creatively,
and then I spend a little time
not thinking about those things
and allowing my brain
and my subconscious mind
to have an opportunity
to do the work for me.
A lot of times when I
come back afterwards,
I've got a great idea,
I've got the answers,
and I have new ways to
solve and resolve things
that I've been thinking about.
- To get into my creative
zone, I do something
that I'd like to call
productive procrastination.
I start what I'm working
on way before it's due,
and then in fits and starts,
I work while giving my mind
permission to wander to things
that absolutely are not on the agenda.
It's encouraged some of my
most creative experiences,
some of my best songwriting,
educational videos,
and even scientific breakthroughs
while I was supposed to be working
on something totally unrelated.
This won't work for everyone,
but my mind is most creative
when it's free to go on
unplanned adventures.
Good music also helps.
A great playlist to me is
worth its weight in gold.
My playlists are special,
because they only include
instrumental music and songs
in languages that I don't actually speak,
so my thoughts don't get too pulled
into the lyrics themselves.
(upbeat music)